this is a conversation with the
inimitable avi loeb
we talk about well i was struggling
what can i talk to avi about that he
hasn't covered before because he's been
on
over 400 podcasts he tends to give the
same
answers and be asked the same questions
it took quite some time but
along with the community we managed to
conceive of questions that he hasn't
been asked
at least not in the public forum such as
what are his opinions on bob lazar
morality purpose a finality to the
universe the beginning of the universe
some technical questions about manifolds
and the lower bound on the mass of
elementary particles and astrophysical
data god
quite a few topics if you'd like to see
more conversations like this or hear
more conversations like this then please
consider
supporting donating whatever you would
like at
patreon.com literally every single
one of the patrons helps a tremendous
tremendous tremendous amount
thank you so much for all the people who
have continued to donate
and thank you for those of you who are
going to just so you know soon i'll be
hosting a three-way conversation between
myself
donald hoffman and bernardo castro it
may be a four-way conversation
if we can get jonathan verveiki in as
well although
i'm unsure if he's available however
it's at least going to be bernardo
castro
and donald hoffman that's coming shortly
we're looking to hit 50 patrons and then
i'll be able to conduct that
thank you thank you so much i appreciate
it and enjoy the interview
i want to know how much did writing your
book or writing books in general or
articles how much does that clarify your
thinking
oh the main purpose for writing the book
as i told the publisher was to
broadcast that excitement that we can
have in science
discovering important things that do
affect our daily lives
and i told the publisher that if one
person around the world will decide to
become a scientist after reading my book
i will be satisfied and as it turns out
a few a few weeks ago i got an email
from malawi
from a woman who wrote the the book is
great
and i'm thinking of becoming an
astronomer so i told her the story about
the publisher and i asked her are you
the one are you that person that will
become a scientist
thanks to reading my book and she said
maybe
so i invited her to apply
to graduate school and at harvard in
astronomy
and i very much hope that she will do so
and then i can work with her
uh there was another undergraduate
student from
colombia that they wrote to me and said
the reading about your work
changed my life and so i get about a
dozen
emails of this type every day now and
i am really satisfied about writing my
book
it wasn't so much for me to clarify
my thinking as to communicate my
excitement about doing science and
you know the fact that we can maintain
our childhood curiosity we can be
excited about doing it
it's not a job like being in the
business world the commercial world
where you get paid and then you use the
money for what you
really enjoy uh in fact you know i would
enjoy doing what i'm doing irrespective
whether i get
money for it there were no problems that
you
had as ambiguous in your mind that when
you started writing then it helped you
elaborate it or cultivate it or
disambiguate it
it was already somewhat formed in your
mind now you just got to put it on paper
yeah i mean it's all in my my head to
start with
and it's just a question of putting it
in a way that is compelling
and you know it's very much the same
when i do my science very often someone
comes to my office and says
this is what i'm working on sort of
immediately i come up with
suggestions for ideas and how to proceed
and
very often that person says oh wow i
how did you come up with that i i didn't
really think about it and
it's not as if it takes me a great
effort to do that it's sort of
in my head to start with and i'm just
explaining it and there is not much
distance between putting it on paper and
having it in my head the only difference
is
this way many other people know about it
okay talking about communicating ideas
to
other scientists i recall you saying
that when you were in your younger years
you would speak about ideas and then
they would get rebuffed but then someone
who is on the periphery listening in
would then advance those ideas and maybe
they would be advanced to the level of
becoming new fields in physics or
insights or or inventions and so on
can you give me some examples of that
yeah it happened several
times and you know early on in my career
i
i looked for um affirmation for
other people um to accept an idea that i
proposed before
i would advocate for it and uh very
often i was disappointed because
i'll give you an example um 21 years ago
i
thought that you know it would be
interesting to to see if there is a
correlation between the mass of black
holes at the centers of galaxies
and the the the depth
of the gravitational potential well that
they're embedded in so in other words
if black holes grow they behave like
kids you know they
eat as much food as they can from the
table until they become too energetic
and then they throw off the food from
the table and
so if that's the case then black holes
would grow
up to a certain mass at which point they
release so much energy they become so
energetic that they clean off
the food that allows them to continue to
grow and
so i suggested let's check if black hole
masses are correlated with
the depth of the gravitational potential
well of the galaxy that hosts them
and the way to measure that is by the
speed by which stars are moving within
that galaxy
near the core of the galaxy and when i
suggest that people said no
that's not interesting it's it's
probably there is nothing interesting in
that
relation and uh i remember mentioning it
at the
conference and it was completely
rebuffed and then
we had a junior faculty search at the
astronomy department and
as it happens in the short list there
were two people working exactly on
on the central black holes in galaxies
and i suggested to both of them
independently
to check that then uh since they were
young people they decided to do that and
they had all the data
in principle i could have done it as
well anyway they did it and each of them
got so excited a few months later they
said
wow there is a very tight correlation
between the black hole mass and
the characteristic speed of stars in in
the galaxy that hosts it
uh and then they decided to publish and
they published exactly the same time the
two teams
and then they started fighting with each
other for the credit because it becomes
the hot the hottest thing in the field
and then for for a decade it became the
thing that everyone talks about and
that was the first indication and then a
couple of years later i
uh suggested the to call i had a
sabbatical
at princeton and i suggested to a few
people that were experts in
black holes and and the info of gas onto
black holes i suggested
uh perhaps we should calculate what
happens when there is a hot spot a
region that is very bright orbiting a
black hole very closely
so that you can perhaps map the space
and time around the black hole this way
and they completely dismissed it and
said well there would never be a hot
spot that maintains its integrity that
this is not worth doing uh and so i came
back to
to harvard after the sabbatical and i
suggested it to a postdoc
of mine and we did the calculation we
wrote a few papers
and then just a year and a half ago two
years ago
a group in germany uh discovered exactly
that phenomena
they found a hot spot moving around
the black hole at the center of the
milky way galaxy just in the way that we
that i envisioned and they it was
the hotspot was orbiting very close to
the black hole and
so once again um and then uh
i can give you many more examples you
know i gave for example a lecture on
gravitational wave astrophysics which is
a new way of
doing astrophysics astrophysics
traditionally astronomy was based on
light collecting light
but then according to einstein's theory
of gravity when you have massive
objects like black holes that are very
compact they distort space and time
around them and
when they move close to each other they
can send out
waves and these are called gravitational
waves and at the time it was 2013
i thought it's an important subject for
the coming years and
i decided to give a lecture about it in
a winter school for students
and then 10 minutes into my talk one of
the
other lecturers who who was by the way
still
is 20 years younger than me so it has
nothing to do with age
but he he's very conservative he's
how long ago was this this was 2013
january
and he stood up and said
why are you wasting the time of these
graduate students on a subject that will
clearly not be important during their
lifetime
for their careers uh and just two years
later that's allowed in front of
everyone
in front of it yeah that's on video you
can we can
find it uh and you know he was uh
much younger than i am working on
uh star formation and so forth a
conservative
astronomer so to speak but young
relatively young
and so um two years later the ligo
collaboration announced
or discovered the announcement came
uh six months later but then you know in
in august 2015 it was discovered that
there was an event a gravitational wave
event discovered by lago and that
ushered a new era in astrophysics where
gravitational waves are being used to
discover
objects that otherwise do not emit any
light black holes that
come together uh and the nobel prize was
awarded for that a few years ago
and clearly you know these the same
students that were in the audience
were still doing their phds where this
discovery was made
and so saying why are you wasting the
time of these students on a subject that
would never be important was clearly
invalid
and you know it happened to me many
times and at some point like five years
ago i said to myself
the hell with it i i don't need
confirmation from other people you know
it's just
well it makes you know it makes me
depressed that to to
listen to the criticism and then realize
that the this is the the you know the
hottest thing in in in the field later
on a few years later so
how is that possible well it is possible
because uh
people are not do not have the vision
about the future and they're very
they they prefer to dismiss a new you
know
you know new ideas innovation and so
forth just
because it takes them out of their
comfort zone they're used to doing
business as usual and
and so five years ago as or so i decided
to
basically not listen and just do what i
think is right based on
my inner compass and you can see that
that
nowadays you know as a young
scientist i would never be able to
sustain the pressure the the
social pressure that exists around me
right now but um
i'm sort of immune to it by now what
social pressure exists around you right
now what are you referring to
also why did it take you i don't know
how old you are
but why did it take you 59. uh so yeah
it takes me
54. yeah why did it take you until
you're 54. i imagine that
if this occurred to you when you were in
your late 20s maybe three times then by
the time you're 33 or 35 you would say
okay to heck
with it forget what other people think
well maybe i'm a slow learner maybe i'm
also
um you know i do care about what people
i did care about what people think early
on and
you have to understand the entire um
structure of academia
uh relies on other people evaluating
your you throughout
the various stages in order to get
tenure you need a
tenure committee to recommend and that
is based on letters that are obtained
from the community at large so
you need to dance to the music of a lot
of people
in order to be sort of tenured
uh and then the same is true about
getting grants
grant support is you know the selection
committee
committees are often populated by people
that are
mainstream and they have their own
agenda and
they don't welcome innovation as much
uh and to me it's still a miracle that
the ligo experiment was funded in the
first place i was told by
uh important people at the national
science foundation that
nowadays at present time the likelihood
of it being funded would have been very
small it was
the vision of a few people a couple of
decades ago that pushed it through
um it's really hard to imagine that
nowadays
uh the national science foundation or
other federal agencies would
receive an advice from the scientific
community
to embark on a risky project of this
type
and it was not at all clear that it will
reach the sensitivity necessary
and so you know you're you're dependent
throughout your career on many people
that will approve uh your your agenda
and
uh as a result you develop the mentality
of um
listening and and paying attention and
not not deviating too much from the
beaten
path and then that that is
quite common what is not common is
someone like me that
reaches leadership positions you know i
i've been
chair of the astronomy department at
harvard for nine years and
i've chaired many important committees
someone at that level often
um you know behaves
even more as a conformist because
uh because of political consideration
um you have to understand it's just like
looking at the
seashells on the beach you know when a
seashell
first arrives at the beach it looks
special and unique it has special color
special shape but as time goes on you
know the waves
rub seashells against each other and
then they start
to lose their identity and they start to
look like each other
and eventually you end up with sea sand
basically pieces of seashells that are
indistinguishable from each other
and that's what happens in academia you
know each
in the each individual researcher starts
different
but then you rub against many others and
you end up being indistinguishable from
them
okay when i hear that here's what i'm
thinking there's this it's not a quote
but it's a story from steve jobs and he
said
almost the opposite so there it's
obviously a happy middle he said
what you want to do is take people who
are like rocks that are unpolished
and then put them into a rock tumbler
because afterwards they come out like
diamonds so you want to take intelligent
smart people and have them argue
i can see this well as long as the
argument is accepted you know as long as
it's a la
so if you create an environment where
people are
encouraged to challenge each other to
come up with original ideas
to be different then that is
i completely agree that that experience
of
argument and exchanges is helpful but
but if on the other hand you create an
environment where
you know the dominant view where there
is
a group thing where the uh the
folklore of a field dominates and anyone
that suggests something different is
pushed aside
that is bad and that's what i was
referring to uh-huh
uh-huh so if it's geared toward
constructing
and also if it's geared toward some goal
yeah if you look for example
if you look for example i mean the ideal
example is the corridor of bellaps
you know bellaps was established by a
corporation
that has a profit in mind but then in
that corridor they put very creative
people
uh and you know some of them ended up
winning the nobel prize there were lots
of inventions that came out of the
corridor of bellaps
and so putting a lot of creative people
in the same environment and allowing
them
to innovate and giving them an incentive
to innovate
that is the right right right and so i
in that sense i would agree with jobs
that
you know putting them next to each other
is beneficial
but if you on the other hand you put
people together and exert
pressure so that you know they do not
deviate
from what everyone else is thinking
that's bad
so right now the incentives are geared
towards self-preservation or
idea preservation yeah and what can be
done to fix this
one of the questions that i had from the
audience was let's imagine there are
some wacky ideas
obviously you don't want to let in just
any idea there is something
to be said about being too fringe but
then there is something to be said about
having permeable
walls right how do you fix this system
quote unquote
well very very very easily um you
basically evaluate each idea on its
merit
um so the the point is you are not
evaluating the person that mentioned
that
you you're not uh using
uh you know uh the personal traits as a
a way of dismissing an idea which is
very often done
very often the attacks are personal if
you if you see in politics it's very
common
in science it should not be the case in
science we should argue about the ideas
about
and if an idea doesn't make sense you
can easily prove that
um so let me give you a counter you know
like an example
that comes from the opposite side so um
for example with respect to a muammua um
i suggested that it may be of artificial
origin as a possibility and that was
that encountered a lot of opposition now
the latest
alternative to that was that maybe it so
maybe it is a nitrogen iceberg that was
a suggestion and
uh for you can find nitrogen pure
nitrogen
as you need in this case uh in order to
explain the fact we haven't seen a
cometary tail around the
moa and also that it's flat and that is
it was pushed from the
away from the sun all of these facts
will come into uh
we could be explained if it was made of
pure nitrogen and
pure nitrogen for example exists on the
surface of pluto
so the suggestion was let's imagine a
lot of pluto's around other stars
and you chip off their surface with a
high efficiency more than ten percent
uh of all the pluto's are being chipped
off the
and then you send out these rocks and
one of them is
and okay i said they're fine
and then i wrote a paper just a week and
a half ago saying
well if you imagine that to be the case
and it you end up
needing more mass than you have in stars
in the milky way galaxy
by a factor of a hundred actually turns
out
uh and so um what do you mean by that
sorry what do you mean by that and
are you referring to the work by desk
and jackson i believe
dash and jackson yes exactly um
and the reason for that is you know the
the layer
of pure nitrogen on the surface of pluto
is
relatively thin uh so it just makes
a few percent of the mass of pluto most
of most of the mass
is uh you know in in in rock and water
ice and so forth um so
you lose by that and then
so for every bit of nitrogen that you
produce you need much more rock and and
water ice to exist and then on top of
that you need
hydrogen and helium that are much more
abundant than rock so if you do that
just a must budget
how much mass do you need to process in
order to make
enough objects so that you would see one
of them
and we know that you need to produce a
certain you know
uh number of such objects per unit
volume so that we would see one of them
coming within a few years of
the time that we were observing the sky
you know with pan stars
so basically if you just go through the
math which is really simple
straightforward
and also they required that it would
then you know
this object would be just half a billion
years old because otherwise it
would get completely evaporated so if
you put all of these considerations
together you find that
you need a hundred times more mass than
you have available in stars
so even if you take all the mass in
stars multiply by a hundred only then
you will have enough
surface layers of exoplutos
or or pluto like planets around other
stars to make enough objects like a momo
so that you would see one of them during
that mode of observations and then so to
me it makes this scenario very unlikely
so
i just mentioned that you know as an
example of how a scientific debate
should should go uh someone proposes an
idea
and then you discuss the idea on its
merit and you know if they
if you do a calculation that shows that
something is problematic with that
you know that that is a a reason for
concern and
for working on something else so that is
a scientific debate
on the other hand if someone goes to
twitter and says something negative
about
a paper and just doesn't even read it
or or says something negative about a
person
without referring to the details of the
idea or says something negative about
the reference list of a paper rather
than the content of the paper
you know that that is not a viable
scientific discussion so
my point is we can maintain a high level
of integrity in the scientific process
if we just refer to the ideas rather
than
attack people personally and that's the
way we should proceed and
you know most of the time in science you
have to understand most of the time
things are uncertain we just don't have
enough evidence
and therefore we should contemplate
possibilities and that's legitimate
that's part of the scientific process
you can't skip that step you can't say
i know the answer and i don't want to
dismiss other possibilities
even though there is not enough evidence
for your answer to be right
so i think it's good to have
ideas on the table that are viable
scientifically
because then we are exploring exploring
all possibilities and
by the way imagination is extremely
important because
we can't just always restrict our
attention to things that we know from
the past
we will never discover new things that
way
what's jackson's and dash's response to
this i don't know
haven't i all i have seen are personal
attacks
uh not necessarily from them but from
other people
and is that the social pressure that you
were referring to before that previously
let's say five years
younger you wouldn't have been able to
withstand that's a low level you know
that
what you find on on social media which i
you know i don't have any account on
social media so i'm less exposed to that
but
and i'm very grateful for that um you
know i decided
not to have any account when i married
my wife she asked me not to do that
and so i uh agreed not to do that and
i'm and that was
more than 20 years ago and i'm very glad
that i i don't have an account on social
media because
um then i can think creatively and not
be affected i mean of course i'm losing
on some
bits of information that are floating
around on social media but i benefit
much more
by not listening to you know low level
discussions i'm i'm
keeping my eyes on the ball so to speak
not on the audience
uh and so um
so that's one kind of pressure that you
find them on social media but
um i'm sort of resilient to that because
i i don't
monitor it uh but then there are of
course
um you know there are other ways that
people
exert pressure through students and
postdocs you know they are much more
vulnerable they they don't have
uh secure positions so
uh if you create an atmosphere where
some ideas are ridiculed and postdocs
and students
are simply afraid of pursuing them
because of their future careers you know
and
i got a lot of emails from people saying
you know i completely agree with you
uh but i cannot express myself because i
worry about my job prospects and
and that comes from people that are
reality not necessarily at the lowest
level of academia
even people that are you know have
secure positions are worried about that
and then you know this this is unhealthy
um because we want uh an open discussion
uh and scientific discussions a
discussion based on
content not on on the way things
look like or on personal attacks
why is it you think aliens are
considered to be unconventional or so
unconventional that they don't merit
an academic response or an academic
investigation
well there are several aspects first of
all as we discussed before
many ideas are ridiculed for no good
reason
even in the context of black holes or
gravitational waves
as i mentioned to you i remember when i
started
as a postdoc the idea of inflation
cosmic inflation was ridiculed in some
circles of
astronomy so that happens all the time
except
in the and and of course the the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence
you know started 70 years ago so it has
a long history
in the early days it wasn't ridiculed as
much but
but every now and then you know there
was a very negative response of the
community and
since 93 there is no significant federal
funding for this
subject and as a result it was pushed
aside now
the strange thing is that um
for example in in particle physics
uh there was the super conducting super
collider a very big
experimental project that uh
at some point you know the funding for
it stopped and
and then what happened in theoretical
physics is that
that there was a whole culture that
developed after that
that is divorced from feedback from
experiments
and it uh this culture of theoretical
physics became
string theory and the discussions of the
multiverse
and and the extra dimensions and so
forth ideas that have no
evidence to support them so on the one
hand
you have a situation where the
mainstream in
theoretical physics discusses concepts
that have
no foundation in experimental
data and that is accepted
and you know the there are big
communities of people working on these
ideas with
and and they are not even interested in
testing the idea so so
most of the papers are about
mathematical details not about how to
test one idea versus another
and if you suggest the test they shy
away from it and try to
sort of raise enough dust so that you
won't be able to to rule out the theory
and so that's one culture and at the
same time you have in astronomy a
culture that
also as a result of not funding a
research area
is completely negative about something
that is down to earth
so to speak we have it on earth it's
intelligent life technological life
so and we now the one thing that we know
now that wasn't true 20 years ago is
we now know that uh half of
a big fraction of all the sun-like stars
have a
planet the size of the earth roughly the
same separation and
so the earth's sun system is not unusual
and
as a result if you arrange for similar
circumstances you might as well get
similar outcomes
and rather than argue about whether it's
likely or not likely whether we are
unique
special or whether we are very common as
common as
ants are on a sidewalk rather than argue
about that
and by the way i believe in the latter
options you know
we should just search and of course we
will never find the truth if we don't
search and
the strange thing is the current
situation is there is very little
funding
a thousand times less funding for the
search for technological signatures
than there is for the search for dark
matter and frankly
the nature of dark matter will have zero
impact on our daily lives
if um was a technological rally or if we
find other technological relics in space
that would have a huge impact on society
and
society the public is very interested in
this subject and it funds science
so i find the current situation
unacceptable
it would have an impact on society in
the sense of how we view ourselves
yeah there are many different aspects
how we
view our place in the universe you know
and
our aspirations for space if there are
others out there
if there is a smarter kid on the block
and by the way most stars
formed billions of years before the sun
and therefore they may have had
civilizations like
us billions of years before us so we're
arriving relatively late to the game you
know the way i see it is you know we are
born into this world
uh just like actors that are put on a
stage
without a script we don't know what the
play is about
so the first thing to check is whether
there are other actors out there perhaps
they know what's going on because they
have been around for a while
so that's what like searching for
another kid on the block
finding whether there are smarter kids
on you know most likely there were
civilizations that died by now
but we can find relics technological
relics they sent out to space just like
we send
voyager 1 voyager 2 no horizons and so
forth
so it's a very natural to me again it's
a common sense
to invest in the search for such things
i call it space archaeology you know
monitoring for example with the camera
every object that comes into the solar
system from outside
that gets close to earth and and
checking it you know
checking whether it's artificial or
natural by a close-up photograph
because a picture is worth a thousand
words and in my case a picture is worth
66
000 words the number of words in my book
so
i think it's very natural to do this
search and invest
at least the same amount of money we
invest in the search for dark matter
which is also a search in the dark you
know we don't know what the dark matter
is
why not invest hundreds of millions of
dollars or
even a billion dollars that's what we
invested in in ligo to me it sounds like
a straightforward
thing to do a very common sensical thing
to do
but somehow my view is not
dominant they say not only that but
the discussion is being ridiculed and
moreover the community doesn't like me
saying that
uh even though that's the reality of the
situation
when i hear that what i'm wondering is
is there a way to monetize the search
for aliens
because then you can get the private
industry the private sector definitely
definitely and then number two what do
you think about elon musk's mission to
mars okay so those are two questions
privatizing the search for aliens and
then
elon musk definitely i think um if
there are individuals interested in the
search i have some
good ideas about how to do space
archaeology how to examine
interstellar objects that enter the
solar system and come close to earth and
take a photograph of them and
you know that that could be a a new
frontier
in in astronomy that there was never
pursued and
it's um simply because
just a few years ago we discovered the
first intestinal object
so right now you know we have our eyes
open it's
it's a wake-up call for us and uh i
would be glad
to discuss with a wealthy individuals
what can be done to
to advance this frontier i think it
would be a very exciting frontier
even more exciting than gravitational
wave astrophysics
uh or the search for dark matter and
then
it could be you know it could be the
most important
discovery that humanity ever made if we
find conclusive evidence
uh for uh alien technology floating in
space
so given that i think we should
definitely
pursue it uh with the private sector
because
that is completely independent and is
known for its innovation
you know because there are very wealthy
individuals that
became wealthy as a result of taking
risks and
you know innovating in the technological
sector so i think
it would be fantastic to open up new
scientific frontiers
uh that they they can pursue with their
wealth
um the second question about going to
mars i think one aspect of that that was
not explored enough and should
should be explored before we go on that
ship that brings us to mars
is um the health concern you know they
if um down here on earth we are
protected by the earth's magnetic field
from
very energetic particles cosmic rays and
by the atmosphere of the earth
and the environment of the space station
floating just hovering above earth is
also relatively protected but
if you go to mars and you spend a year
actually a significant fraction of
your brain cells can be damaged as a
result of energetic particles
going through the helmet i mean you
can't
you have to be in a cave underground
or to have some special shielding
around you to be protected and there was
not enough
attention given to that and i think that
should be addressed
because we don't want them it to be a
one-way
trip where after a year everyone that
goes there dies
so there's too much of a focus on
building the atmosphere not much of
the lack of a magnetic well yeah so i
mean
one thing is of course to create a
habitat that
allows people to breathe and you don't
need to build a
a whole atmosphere to terraform mars you
can just do it inside a closed vessel
you know and and but at the same time
worrying about the
how to protect humans so that they can
live there for more than a year is i
think a major challenge that was not
addressed enough
and of course you can do it in steps you
can go first to the moon
and then because the moon is closer to
us and we can ship
people back and forth more easily
and that could be a stepping stone to
mars what do you think of sean carroll's
many worlds well it's not his many
worlds interpretation but
he seems to think it's the only game in
town with regard to
quantum mechanical interpretations and
he seems to think it's not as arbitrary
as people say and that maybe there's
some evidence for it
at least if you quote unquote follow the
math so what do you make of that
argument um
well so quantum mechanics was discovered
experimentally and
that's an important lesson for us to
maintain
our humility as scientists you know
sometimes we need the experiments to to
to give us an insight about nature that
we haven't expected
and it takes us out of our comfort zone
and he took albert einstein out of his
comfort zone because he thought
you can't have quantum mechanics with
spooky action at the distance
it makes no sense to him
and so he wrote a paper about it the the
einstein podolski rosen paper
trying to propose an experiment that
will demonstrate that spooky action
at the distance does not exist versions
of that experiment were done and
he was proven wrong and indeed we are
a century later after quantum mechanics
was discovered
still uh feeling uneasy about how to
interpret it
um and this is an excellent example for
why we need experiments because
uh very often uh experiments open us
our eyes to facts that we
you know we haven't anticipated but our
imagination
is limited the more limited than
nature's imagination in a way and we
we should science is basically
just being a student for life as a
scientist
you are you have to be humble and modest
enough to
admit that you know that perhaps nature
uh is different than your preconceptions
and
if you were to say i don't need
verification i know the truth in advance
i know that there are extra dimensions
or i know that um a rock
or i know that this and that without
even checking then you are just like the
philosophers
during the days of galileo that didn't
want to look through his telescope
because they knew that the sun moves
around the earth
so just i just wanted to to make that
point that the
quantum mechanics is really a an
excellent example for why
a scientist we should always regard
ourselves as
students of nature uh but coming back to
so to the question of what's the meaning
of quantum mechanics that
as you mentioned that the there was the
many world interpretation and
uh sean carroll puts it in a modern
context um
and uh obviously does sean carroll add
anything that hasn't been said before on
the many worlds interpretation
from everett um yeah i mean there are
some new nuances
uh now um that relate
to how to to define the wave function
and
the possible existence of the multiverse
that some people
contemplate as you know that the actual
reality is much uh
bigger than what we can experiment with
within the observable universe that we
see
but um i would say that the verdict is
still out
i mean um every year or two i read the
an interesting essay that uh offers new
insights to quantum mechanics the
interpretation of quantum mechanics but
we are not there yet we we haven't
converged on something that everyone
agrees on
and again i think the way to converge
would be
to be guided by experience and and it's
quite possible you know that the one
thing we're missing
is the connection with gravity that we
don't have a quantum theory of gravity
that was tested experimentally and
perhaps
in the context of such a theory the
the concerns we have we will go away
because one thing that
you recognize in quantum mechanics at
least the traditional way it was
formulated in
is that time plays a special role
relative to space and
um whereas in in the general theory of
relativity time and space are just
dimensions
of space time and they can be curved by
objects and so forth so perhaps once we
identify a winning theory that unifies
quantum mechanics and gravity many of
the
ambiguities that we have right now in
physics and by the way there are many
not just not just the interpretation of
quantum mechanics the
there is the information paradox in the
context of black holes and
we don't know what happens to
information that falls into a black hole
um stephen hawking demonstrated that
black holes evaporate
eventually into thermal radiation that
doesn't carry that information so the
question is
if the black hole goes away where where
are all
where is all the information that we
threw into it when we made it
uh and that's a fundamental question
because quantum mechanics
argues that information cannot be
destroyed and so
this is one puzzle that is also unsolved
in modern physics then there is a
question of what
happens in the singularities of either
the singularity of a black hole where
the curvature of space and time
diverges or the singularity of the big
bang what happened before the big bang
do you believe that there are
singularities within
no it's clear that singularities are
just
appearing in einstein's theory of
gravity because it doesn't it's not
unified with quantum mechanics
because once you get to very large
curvatures of space and time
you have to correct the equations that
einstein wrote
because quantum mechanics comes into
play
so again the singularities are just
symptoms
of us having an incomplete theory and
what we need
is to unified quantum mechanics with uh
the general theory of relativity of
einstein and of course string theory is
a very popular contender but
when you ask string theories can you
tell me what what happens in the
singularity of a black hole they say
oh that's the too difficult question we
can't really address it at this point
when you ask them what happens at the
big bang just before the big bang
they say oh that's too difficult we
can't really and then there are people
that try to formulate some
guesses as to how string theory would
behave
but um so first of all there is not
a unique answer from string theory right
now
and the theory is not unique in its
predictions
and second uh on the issues that matter
it doesn't put any skin in the game it
doesn't say here is a prediction that
you can test
experimentally and if if you find one
answer then string theory is right if
you find another answer then it's wrong
no they prefer not to put skin in the
game so that it will still be right
forever
and there is even the claim that if by
some
philosophers that if physicists agree on
something for a decade it must be right
and i find that
really embarrassing that people argue
that uh
which philosophers oh there is uh
there is the weed no um
there is a philosopher with uh that that
wrote a book
about string theory and suggesting that
you know we should
adjust our conception of what physics is
supposed to mean that uh experiments may
not be needed and that
in fact physics is what physicists do
and once again from my perspective i
hold exactly the opposite view i think
that
you know nature educates us we are just
students of nature so
we should be modest and learn from
experiments we can't
imagine that we will know the truth in
advance you know it
to me it sounds like hallucinations like
you are high on drugs if you believe
that you can that reality always
reflects what you think it is
uh that's what people that are you know
that hallucinating
but you can think that you're the the
wealthiest person in the world and
when you go to the bank and check how
much money you have in your checking
account
you realize that you know that's an
experiment and you realize that
you cannot cash it uh so i mean of
course people can feel happy
i have nothing against that they can do
mathematical gymnastics and feel happy i
just have
the objection i have is about that
applying to reality
a reality check needs to happen at some
point right exactly
otherwise i mean you can just celebrate
something that is not real
okay let's talk about bob lazar i sent
you an email and i asked you
if you had the time to please watch this
video was a technical explanation of bob
lazar in his younger years
did you have a chance to even skim it
yeah i skimmed it and then
i what i found on on the web is that um
he made a lot of statements without ev
showing any evidence and
you know here i give usually the example
of napoleon
you know there were many people over the
years that claimed that they are
napoleon and how do you check that
once again experimentally you ask them
show me your id
and if they can't show you the idea that
says that they are naporeon
and if they keep insisting that they are
naporeon without showing you evidence
for that
you know there are places where you can
put them
and my point is evidence is the key
that's the way that uh science
gets credibility that that that's the
way for us to make progress as i
discussed before for us to learn new
things
through experiments through evidence and
it's just
it's not just a nuance uh looking for
evidence is not just something that you
can
give up on it's a necessity
that's the only thing that will keep you
sane
and making relevant statements and
you can make a lot of statements that
look bizarre
interesting intriguing emotionally
appealing
you know you can make a lot of
statements like that and in fact our
culture is full of that
you have all kinds of myths in our
culture
you know if you can think about lots of
them i mean
santa claus i mean there are lots of
myths that are accepted
uh and they're part of our culture but
they're not regarded as possible you're
crushing me right now i thought santa
claus is real
oh man summarize my point is uh when i
checked a lot of the things he said
he didn't bring um credible evidence to
support them and
that's what makes me worried that you
know and
that he he's not real
ah ah i see i see did you take a look at
any of his explanations as to how the
spacecraft
would work and is it feasible in your
mind is it
untenable is it ridiculous no i mean
once again suppose he had a good idea
for making a spacecraft that
we currently do not do not have okay
that nasa is not developing
he could have made a fortune out of it
how
very simply instead of talking about it
he could have built it
and then it would fly what's the problem
i mean that's a straightforward i don't
understand why we need to talk about it
even
i mean any reasonable person that has an
idea that is not being used
and that could make millions or even
billions
of dollars you know first of all
establishes a patent on that
and secondly you know tries to build
this thing
and if it's real he will make that
profit you know
it would be bigger than tesla it would
be bigger than spacex
because you would find a technology that
nasa can use
that nobody thought about so you know it
makes
zero sense to say i know how to do
something
and not reveal the details and not build
it
if you know how to do it just build it
that's what i tell kids when they come
to me with ideas
okay i believe what he was saying is
that he doesn't know how it works
what happened was he was told to work on
some craft and he believes they're of
alien or extraterrestrial origin
and that the us government knows how to
pilot them to some degree
in the same way that you can learn how
to use a phone or a tablet like
they've dropped phones and tribes and
they know how to turn it on
but they don't know how it works and he
said possibly the way that it works is
with
this element called element 115 and
there's a strong nuclear
force which turns into a gravitational
force now that i find interesting i
don't know how it works but to me if
that's true that's
that's one way of unifying quantum field
theory with gravity
either way what do you think about that
from the point of view of a physicist
this is just nonsense
i mean it makes more sense i i've never
heard about how you turn
the nuclear force into a gravitational
force in any
piece of equipment of course if you
reach the planck scale you might
be able to do something but you know no
accelerator
gets even closer the only time when we
reach that scale perhaps was at the big
bang
or near a singularity of a black hole
but so i i would say
this is just not i mean it makes no
scientific sense to me
and uh moreover let's imagine that he
did not know the details but someone
else has that equipment
why do you think that someone else will
keep it secret why won't they
just use it or develop it and and
you know get a great advantage relative
to others
by using it i was listening to one of
you actually
i believe you said this plenty of times
that
someone said to you deflation is not
disprovable
i'm sorry inflation is not disprovable
yeah okay
do you mind explaining why okay so here
is the
thing that cosmic inflation
is a theory that was proposed um about
um
40 years ago and it was meant to explain
some very peculiar facts about the
universe
one of which let me just mention because
it's really simple to
to follow uh when we look in one
direction
uh in the on the sky we find the cosmic
microwave background relic from the
big bang with some temperature okay then
we look at the
opposite direction on the sky and we
find the cosmic microwave background
having exactly the same temperature
now how is that possible it took the age
of the universe
for the this light to arrive to us from
these two points on the sky
and these two points on on the sky did
not have time to communicate with each
other because it would take
twice as long at least or more than that
for the
light to arrive from one point to
another to the other
so how come the universe was arranged in
a way
such that conditions are the same
or throughout the entire sky in terms of
the cosmic microwave background
temperature for example
so we know the universe had similar
initial conditions
uh to one part in a hundred thousand
uh throughout the region that we can see
meaning that in one part in a hundred
thousand it's the same temperature or
what
yes yes uh and how
how come it was prepared in such a state
which is very
special you know if you had if you would
imagine a
just a random state you would have very
different temperatures in different
places
so inflation attempts to explain that
the idea is that
uh everything that we see came from a
very small patch
that was stretched exponentially in time
very quickly
uh so points that were in contact with
each other were separated
very fast faster than light from each
other and that is possible based on
einstein's theory of gravity you can
separate
points exponentially away from each
other
if the vacuum itself dominates gravity
which by the way is what is happening
right now in the universe the
expansion of the universe is
accelerating as of recently
over the past half of the history of the
universe the the expansion is
speeding up rather than slowing down and
the idea is that the same thing happened
at a very early
time and then that
took a small region of space that where
points were connected to each other had
the same conditions
and spread them apart sorry just i want
to make sure i'm understanding is this
just a change of the metric with the
cosmological constant
and so there so inflation is just saying
the cosmological constant was large in
the early universe and then somehow
became smaller yeah exactly and
the cosmological constant is equivalent
to the vacuum
having some mass density some energy
density
which by the way today is called dark
energy i mean it's basically the energy
of the back
so by the vacuum i mean if you clean up
all the matter
whatever you have left is the backing
and the vacuum could have
a uniform energy density the same energy
density
everywhere uh because it's the vacuum
it's the ground state
so if you just imagine at the early
cosmic time the vacuum had
a large energy density and that went
away
it was sort of a false vacuum the vacuum
was excited to some higher state
and then it decayed into the vacuum we
have today
then that will create an exponential
expansion that is called
a cosmic inflation early on and would
explain some facts about the universe
it could also generate it will make the
universe
have the same conditions everywhere but
it also through quantum mechanics
generates small
ripples in the the density of matter
one percent ripples yeah small
fluctuations
small small fluctuations because of
quantum mechanics
that later grow and become the galaxies
that we see today or
the objects that we see today so so
that's that's the nice
the beauty of the concept of cosmic
inflation that it explains
a lot of things and that's why it was
widely accepted after
after a while in the scientific
community uh
sorry i just want to make sure i'm
understanding this correctly so is the
way that they put a
bound on the time that the cosmological
constant was
extremely high is it with by observing
the
cosmic background radiation and saying
okay there's a one percent difference
about one in a hundred you said right no
one in a hundred thousand
yes okay one in a hundred thousand so
then that means that there's a
a bound as to how long that could go on
for because otherwise the fluctuations
would be so large that we would see
larger gaps
i mean larger variations so that there
is there is a lower limit on how long it
persisted which is
you need to inflate enough so that
the small patch would become as big as
the universe today
okay that's uh that's the minimum you
need to expand by
but it could have expanded much more
than that we just don't know
so inflation could have lasted much more
you know we we have no upper limit on
how long it lasted
but we have a lower limit uh and and we
know that it should have ended so that
we will
end up with universe full of matter
that made every all the objects we see
now so the vacuum could not have con
continued to dominate the expansion
forever because then we wouldn't exist
so the vacuum dominated for a while and
that while
lasted at least 60
periods of exponential expansion at
least 60
and then after that it you know we don't
know how much more but
eventually it decayed and became the
matter that we have
today and and the universe entered into
its expansion the way we see it
um so anyway unfalsifiable because
okay no so that idea
as it was formulated initially was a
very interesting idea because you can
test it
there are various predictions uh one of
them is that
the geometry of the universe would be
flat and
and so forth and and by the way it was
confirmed the the
the universe is flat you know if you
draw a triangle the sum of the angles is
180 degrees and so forth
but at some point uh it became clear
that
to account for inflation you actually
come up with
uh the multiverse uh
there are lots of other regions in
inside of which
conditions could be very different so
anything that is possible
happens an infinite number of times
in such a theory of cosmic inflation so
once you
allow for not just our reality to exist
but you have
all kinds of regions where things
everything that can happen happens
an infinite number of times then it
starts losing its predictability because
anything that you find about our
universe could you could
it's a very flexible theory now that
can explain anything and so i had a
panel discussion with alan guth
that is one of the pioneers of inflation
and in which
i asked him a simple question i said and
that was
about five years ago i asked him is
inflation forsifiable
is there an experiment by which you will
detect something
about the cosmic micro background or
about the universe
and that will demonstrate that inflation
is wrong
can you envision something i'm not
saying necessarily that it's wrong i'm
just saying is there a way to test it
skin in the game as you would call it
yeah and he said
that's a silly question he said uh
any observational fact uh in the
universe can be a
inflation right now as a theory is
sufficiently flexible
that it can explain can accommodate any
fact that you detect
and to me a theory of everything is not
very far from being a theory of nothing
because if you can explain anything that
you find
then what's the value of the theory it
doesn't give you any added
value because first you find it and then
the theory says
yes yes of course a version of the
theory would make it
so what did i learn i didn't learn that
theory is right
i didn't love the theory i cannot learn
that theory is wrong
and therefore it loses its scientific
value in my view
not in the view of alan good he thinks
that
it makes the theory very robust because
it can agree with anything that is being
found
and you know that is the shift in the
culture that i'm
worried about you see this with string
theory as well
yes i'm not sure if alan is a string
theorist
well no he's not but the two cultures
uh you know celebrate to get uh the same
the same view about how physics can be
done nowadays
they both i mean also in the context of
string theory
you know for example there was a
suggestion
that the uh you know some it has a
landscape and and
in its landscape the landscape of the
string theory uh
accounts for some uh versions of
inflation and so i asked the person that
worked on that i said okay so this
connection that you make between
the natural incarnation of string theory
and
uh and inflation suppose we measure
something in the cosmic microwave
background about inflation and we show
that the kind of
inflation that you are advocating is
wrong would that prove
string theory wrong and that person said
no
string theory will always be right what
it will
prove is the connection that i made
between string theory and inflation
that connection is wrong so you see
there are the psychology is always to
retreat
uh to a place that cannot be
shown wrong and although it sounds very
appealing and comfortable
because you can maintain your image as
you know being always right and you
don't
put any skin in the game it's not really
what physics is about
this flatness that you mentioned of
space-time is this why we can say that a
galaxy is moving away from us at a
certain speed and the reason why i say
that is
in a manifold you can't technically to
get a bit technical can't technically
compare two different velocities unless
they're brought at the same point unless
you have
a horizontal or vertical subspace given
by a connection and so on
so how can you compare different
velocities when you're at different
points in a manifold that's what i'm
wondering
no so first of all i should say that in
einstein's theory of gravity you can get
a very distant galaxy to move away from
us
faster than light and that is because
it's far away
so space and time can expand faster than
light
when you're dealing with points that are
separated by a large distance
that's allowed by einstein's theory and
that's why
we lose contact with galaxies once they
start moving faster than light relative
to us
and so in an accelerating universe two
points that were in contact
are separated eventually so that they
are not in contact anymore after a while
and of course that time that it takes is
the time that it takes them to reach the
speed of light basically that's the time
that they're still in contact and after
that they're not in cont
that they cannot communicate um but
to your second question that has to do
with how
can we measure that the universe is flat
and that is simply just like
um you check if a piece of paper is flat
you draw a triangle and you check the
sum of the angles
if the sum of the angles is 180 degrees
you know that this piece of paper is
flat
but if it sits on top of a ball for
example
then the sum of the angle can be bigger
than
180 degrees you can take a line from the
pole to the equator
go along the equator and go back to the
pole
and each of these angles would be 90
degrees
so 90 plus 90 plus 90 if you're doing it
that would be 270 it's more than 180
degrees then you know that
the surface is not flat it's actually
curved
like a ball positive so
how do we check the sums of the angles
of a triangle
in the universe well we just need a
standard ruler
and we have that uh in the early
universe you know
a sound wave would propagate a certain
distance
that we can calculate so at a given time
after the big bang we know how far
a sound wave can propagate and it turns
out that this is the distance where you
can have
correlations between the temperature
of the microwave background because
sound waves
correlate different points in the sky
where the temperature of the micro
background
knows about another point sorry why are
you using sound waves because
sound waves require a medium yes there
is a medium the matter in the universe
is the medium i mean there is
ordinary matter and there is light and
there is dark matter
so there is matter uh and and the sound
waves
we can calculate the speed by which they
move and so if we look at a certain time
after the big bang
we can tell how far sound waves could
propagate and that defines the standard
ruler
that's the distance over which different
points in the sky would be correlated
with each other because they could speak
via sound with each other and so when we
look at the micro background
we can measure the angle that that
yardstick
occupies and we can figure out whether
the sums
of the angles in that triangle the base
of the triangle
is the yardstick the distance that sound
traveled at that time
and then the the other sides of the
triangle bring
go to the observer so the observer looks
at this yardstick
and we can look at how what is the angle
that this yardstick occupies
and from that we can figure out that
whether the universe is flat or not and
this experiment was done in in the year
2000
uh we already knew that the universe is
flat
that it's the simplest geometry you can
think of that's absolutely
interesting of a flat space a priori is
there a reason why it should be flat
i see it's as simple but and also is
there a margin of error with this
well there should be a margin of error
there is a margin of error all right
the precision right now is a few percent
uh
but um cosmic inflation naturally
you know in the all the incarnation of
it where not everything was possible but
if you were to take the models from 1980
um they would expect the universe to be
flat because
you take a small patch of space you
might have some curvature of space and
time in that patch
but then you inflate it and when you
inflate it you stretch it
to huge dimensions so all the curvature
that you had on small scales
is now being ironed out and
you can think of it as a cosmic iron you
basically iron out by
expansion you cl you make the universe
flat
the geometry flat and it happens to be
the case that the universe is flat
indeed
that seems to me to be evidence for the
inflation yes it is
but in the original incarnation of the
1980s
uh what happened afterwards is that the
theory was
appended supplemented by ingredients
that make it
much less predictive that it can
accommodate anything
that's the part that they resist i see i
see
let's imagine i think wolfram predicts
that there's a lower bound to the
elementary particle masses or at least
he says he can get to that
i think you mentioned that astrophysical
data can validate this
how well wolfram has a different
way of looking at physics uh
which is related to um something he
worked on
for a while it's diagrams of
hyper graphs and so on yeah temperatures
and he has a group of people working
with him and
it's a very ambitious process project
he is very bright i
i haven't seen yet that the effort
yield predictions that we can test
experimentally
so far he's trying to reproduce things
we know about
and then he's actually
not far from where i live and he's
relatively local
how many minutes am i driving
yeah at some point i i hope to to have a
conversation with him walking together
in the woods and
trying to get the latest on his work
but as far as i know it's not yet at the
point where
the theory predicts new things that we
can test beyond what we already know
i see i see so what do you think of his
model
i think it's too preliminary it's it's
nice to have people thinking
independently you know and
um i i very much i i salute his
effort intellectually because it's very
ambitious you know to come up with a
completely new way of looking at physics
and his courage for do taking on this
task
uh and his intellect i mean he's he's
brilliant
when you listen to him have you heard of
eric weinstein's geometric unity
have you researched into it and what do
you think about it i did not
look into it in detail no
so i cannot comment but i know that he's
very bright
yeah do you think that innovation in
physics is going to necessarily come
from the outside because of these
selective pressures that you mentioned
in the
in academia yeah well i think uh
what it what happens is that this
pressure
is is reducing the efficiency of science
that
fewer people are attempting to deviate
from the beaten path
and especially the young people you know
if you think about albert einstein he
was not deterred by
oppression he in one year had five
seminal papers and i very much hope that
this tradition will come back
where young people will not be afraid to
innovate
uh and uh i think
even with social pressure as long as we
continue to do experiments you know
that's the key
because experiments and collecting
evidence will eventually
tell us that we are wrong it takes more
time
if we are not open-minded and if you
look for example
the perfect example is the mayan culture
i
i when i visited the mexico
i went to chichen itza uh and the tour
guide then
was bragging about the mayan culture and
saying that the astronomers in that
culture were held
at a very high regard they were
considered astronomer priests
the highest level in society and i was
wondering why and
turns out that uh politicians
the rulers of the mayans they thought
that
by knowing the positions of planets and
stars on the sky
you can forecast the future so you can
tell the outcome of a war you can decide
when to go out to a war
so that it will be successful so that
you would win based on the locations of
planets and so they put astronomers
that monitor the sky the planets where
did they get that idea from
just from the predictive powers of the
weather and then extrapolating that
no it's just a it's um it's sort of like
horoscopes nowadays you know astrology
uh it's a natural tendency of people to
believe that
there are powers that extend way beyond
what reality is
you know and alchemy was one example
where people thought that their
beliefs or emotions affect you know
materials the nature of materials
so anyway they thought that
the motion of stars and planets affect
human history and that's
astrology fundamentally so but
that was their belief system and then
and then the astronomers collected huge
amounts of data over
thousands of years and uh amazing data
but it was not used for the purpose of
finding
uh newton's law of gravity it was for
the purp for the political purpose of
winning a war
and if you think about it from a modern
perspective
we now know that the motion of mars or
or
venus have nothing to do with whether
the gulf war was successful or a
disaster
and so we nowadays have a different view
about planets
and stars and collecting all this
exquisite data was not enough
if you have the wrong conception good
data
is not enough so you need to be
open-minded
for other interpretations and to think
about the data that you get in ways that
are not traditional
and i bring this up because if you
always think that you know the answer in
advance
you might not even collect the data
that's even more dangerous
the mayans were in a way more advanced
than
those people that say we don't need data
we know the answer without it
you know those philosophers let's say if
physicists agree on something that's
enough
that's that's much more primitive than
the mayans
uh belief system because the minds were
collecting data about the sky
at least and and you know the
i think that's the most important thing
that we can
maintain in terms of the integrity of
science is its reliance on evidence
rather than on what people say
and i hope if that stays
even if some ideas are ridiculed now
eventually there would be data and
evidence that would
demonstrate that they're right and
that's what happened to me you know in
the examples that we
discussed at the beginning of our
conversation you know that eventually
data came along and demonstrated that
what i'm saying is correct
and so that that is you know great i
mean
and by the way it's not about me being
right it's not about us it's about
right it's about the dialogue we have
with nature i recall reading one of your
scientific american articles about the
limitations of knowing a theory of
everything and you cited girdle
i'm not sure if you were citing girdle
to say that what girdles incompleteness
theorem has to say
is something about whether or not we can
ultimately find the laws that govern us
or you're using that to say well look
there are limitations so let's be a bit
more humble
which one was it does girdle's theorem
have anything to do
it was the second one i think we should
be humble because
we will never have a complete theory of
everything
uh logically that was demonstrated by
ghetto but
but also you know the scientific process
is working progress you know we
it turns out that when we discover new
things uh we can ask more questions
it's not that we ask less questions so
the the illusion that you know physics
will get to an
end and that would be it you know that
was uh
advocated that a hundred years ago
before
uh einstein came more than a hundred
years 100
yeah 20 years ago before einstein came
with special relativity and quantum
mechanics was discovered
and clearly physics was revolutionized
and it's being
it was said the in recent decades by
some people and
again i i think they are completely
misguided because
uh you know knowledge is just an island
in an ocean of ignorance we we know so
little
and the way to for us to maintain
the integrity of science is to stay
modest and say look we we don't know so
much
and and it's work in progress and
sometimes we may be wrong so let's be
open-minded and let's continue to
collect evidence and and make progress
through that
why does girls in completeness theorem
have anything to do with
whether or not we can learn uh
fundamental laws because
what ghetto demonstrated is that you
cannot build a
a self-consistent logical
system that uh that that
can be proven uh and and and be
self-contained so to speak
i see i see you you're talking about
whether or not we can prove that
our theory of everything is the theory
of everything so there will always be
some loopholes even at the logical level
uh but what i'm referring to in addition
to that is the fact that uh
reality you know it will take us a long
while before we figure out all the
details of reality through experiments
in addition to the logical issues i
recall you mentioned
that science sorry that religion can
learn from science obviously in the
sense that we investigate nature it
tells us more about
god as well as it allows us a deeper
appreciation of that nature
and this is an old view actually which
says that if you have an interpretation
of the bible
the christian bible and you find that
nature
contradicts that then it's not that
nature is wrong is that your
interpretation of the bible is wrong
nature is always right because nature is
what god made
nature is god in some way actually so
then i'm wondering
that means that religion can learn from
science okay can science
learn from religion and if so how
well yeah so you know
being a physicist is just like trying to
figure out
what a building is is made of you know
you're trying to figure out
the bricks and mortar that make the
building that's the fundamental laws of
physics and
uh when we look at the universe we're
trying to figure out what it's made of
what the composition of the universe
what are the laws that are governing it
and then lo and behold we find that the
most most of the matter in the universe
is in some form that we don't know what
what what it is and we are not made of
it it's called dark matter so we still
have to figure it out
you know it's a puzzle and we're trying
to figure out uh
also the laws that govern the behavior
of the universe
but if you look at the building
there is more to it than the bricks and
mortar that make the building
the there is the design and there is the
uh purpose of the building and there is
the meaning of the building
you know and that goes beyond physics
that's the metaphysics now a physicist
can take a practical approach and say i
don't really care about that
i want to figure out how reality
operates because that's the only
tangible thing that i can later use in
developing technology
uh you know i i don't want to think
about
things that i cannot test empirically
like
you know that involve beauty
is the building beautiful is the
building serving a bigger purpose that's
that's not of my
interest but if you're an architect
right and you care mostly about that you
don't care about the bricks and mortar
uh as an architect you you draw a blue
blueprint of a building and you know in
principle
the con construction workers could use
different
materials to to make that
uh of course the materials affect the
durability of the building and so forth
but
but not so much the way uh
it appears and and functions and uh so
from the point of view of an architect
it's a completely different question you
know
than from the point of construction work
what the building represents and
so the way i i see that is that reality
you know it
has many facets to it and
one of the facets is indeed what the
physics is dealing with
but another facet is what the humanities
are dealing with and
and that include includes philosophy and
theology and
religion and then you know as a human
you are incomplete if you were not to
consider all the facets
i mean you can of course narrow yourself
to one of them and just say i don't care
about anything else
that's fine but that's uh in a way
narrow-minded you know
it's just like looking at a small piece
of the of the big picture and i think
you're not
um fully satisfied living like that i
mean i don't think
uh that ignoring the humanities is a
good practice
i'm reminded by aristotle who had a
concept of causation which unified what
you're referring to
so material cause efficient cause formal
and final so the material is what you
brick some order and then the efficient
is essentially causation as we
understand it as physicists and the
formal is okay the
architecture and then the final is the
purpose of it so you're saying we've
forgotten about formal and final as
physicists or as
materialists in some way but then
aristotle's causation was secular
and what i was wondering is how can
science learn from religion
and that to me doesn't unless you want
to call what
aristotle was doing as religious where's
traditional religion in that
in your answer okay so traditional
religion that
has a god that looks over your shoulder
and affects what happens to you
you know that is you know that you can
falsify if you
you know in principle bad things happen
to good
people and vice versa and uh
and you know you can operate
if you are using the scientific method
uh you can test
those predictions you know if if there
is a way by which you can forecast what
will happen
and you see that that not happening that
that
or you know if the biblical story of
abraham in the bible if
abraham heard the voice of god and he
had a cell phone where he had a
voice memo app and he would have pressed
the button he could have recorded the
voice of god so
you know it in principle it's possible
to test some of these
direct interactions uh between a divine
entity
and and the human but if you believe
more in the concept the philosophical
concept
like spinoza did where he identified
god with nature and
you know there is something to it
because nature itself is not completely
random you know it's organized and
that's quite striking that the laws of
physics create
some order in the universe that
otherwise would not exist and
the fact that the same laws of physics
that we find here on earth apply
everywhere is remarkable in my view
and you know discovering the laws of
physics gives you a sense of
oh of the type that a religious person
may feel
you know because you are feeling
something about nature that you
uncovered that
is remarkable that applies everywhere
and it's much greater than we are
because it applies everywhere so um
you can call it a religious sense a
sense of
oh but you're doing it through a
scientific lens
and frankly it's not obvious to me that
there is a bigger meaning to life
uh you know like the because if you
think about the meanings that we assign
to life
they're usually confined to earth
all of our ambitions are confined to
earth
and within a billion years the sun will
boil off
all the oceans on earth so nothing that
we care about
that that is dear to our heart will stay
around for more than a billion years so
then you ask yourself
is that really a valuable meaning
something that will go away okay it will
go away in a billion years not in a
in a hundred years but qualitatively
speaking
it will go away it's just like something
that goes away in a week
i mean it may be meaningful for a while
but then it's not anymore so
there is no absolute meaning to our
existence if you think about the big
picture
and you know one thing that people ask
me what is the one thing you would
like to ask an alien if you were to be
in contact that is the question i would
like to ask is there a meaning to this
or what is the what is the meaning of
this play and as i said at the beginning
we are put on the stage like actors
without a script
what's the play about i would like to
know that
do you think that because we can zoom
out and say that over across a billion
years let's say that
will no longer be here therefore it's
meaningless do you think that
that means it's meaningless or do you
think that means that that view that we
zoom out and look
at our lives across a billion years that
that is not a way that we should view
ourselves the reason i'm saying that is
if we say that it's meaningless because
there's a there's an end to it then why
can't we just go
to a holocaust museum and say well their
suffering didn't matter because there
was an end to it anyway
like why can't we just apply that even
more locally and there is a meaning
but it's a temporary of course and um
and of course it it you know it means uh
the world
to us because we are also short-lived
you know we we live just
for decades and you know 100 years or so
uh
and um so during that time you know
that's what matters to us
what happens during that time and that's
extreme but when i was referring to
meaning i was referring to something
bigger that is
that is not going to go away you know
something that stays forever
and that's the thing that we need to
give up on i think
and and again uh staying modest you know
i think
it allows you not to want too much
you know not to think that oh there you
know i really want something that will
stay forever
perhaps we should yeah as you say
perhaps we should admit that
everything is temporary everything
changes all the time
we should just adapt to changing
circumstances and the meaning that we
have is
always short-lived and we should be
happy about that you know we can enjoy
good food when we eat it
we can enjoy the company of friends when
we have them around
uh and after a while it goes away that's
okay that's that's the way
life is and if we we don't aspire for a
meaning that is beyond that
that's okay
something i was toying with was i wonder
if there's a way that the world of
experience can last forever
and the reason is let's say in general
relativity right beside a black hole
you can watch your person your friend
enter the black hole infinitely for the
rest of time
obviously they'd have to send photons
back to you but you can watch them it's
almost as if they're frozen right at the
event horizon
but then for them it's as if they passed
into the black hole now let's imagine in
reverse right before you're about to die
your experience of life gets stretched
infinitely
to everyone else it's as if it ended but
then
in just like in general relativity you
can't say that your frame of reference
is the correct one that they're your
friends is just as valid so i'm
wondering
does your experience it's not something
we can test but i'm wondering if right
before you die
does it get stretched infinitely and
that's one of the reasons why they say
heaven and hell
exist because and also heaven and hell
is dependent on how you live your life
right now because if you live
as if you're in heaven or you live
properly or you live as if you're in
hell and you hate everyone
if you were to die you're going to feel
that stretched out for the rest of
your life now you won't be able to see
other people but somehow
phenomenologically or experientially
it will get stretched and that's a huge
speculative jump
well that's that's an interesting
thought but if you ask me for my opinion
i think that we are just our body is
just like
a computer and when you unplug it from
the wall it shuts off all the systems
shut off and that's the experience of
death
basically your you know your your cord
is taken out of the
outlet do you have any ideas as to
consciousness or
its origins is it emerged is
consciousness emergent
yeah that's what i think i think um that
we are very complex
systems and we are subject
to a lot of uh inputs
you know from our environment and that's
what makes us
unpredictable so when people talk about
free will it's
sort of the confluence of a lot of
ingredients
each of which you know can change the
outcome and
as a result we are not that predictable
and
of course according to quantum mechanics
things are not predictable
there is a probabilistic outcome
but in general you know i think
both free will and consciousness are
incarnations of very complex systems so
it's it's the way that
a complex system the human appears uh
but it doesn't mean that the building
blocks of making a human
are anything different than you know the
physical elements
that we know about you just put them
together in some way
and you get phenomenal like
consciousness
which by which we mean that the the
system itself recognizes that it exists
uh and acts based on the feedback that
it gets from reality
but in principle i can imagine
us constructing entities that will
behave the same way
in the future you know robots that are
sufficiently advanced with
ai and so forth i don't see a
qualitative difference between the human
body
and and the materials that that it's
made of it's just that there are
the materials are organized in a way
that gives the human body special
qualities
and abilities but
when we die it's just like taking the
computer chord out of the outlet i'm
sure you've heard of the hard problem of
consciousness
that is how can we get experience from
what's
fundamentally not experiencing do you
have any ideas as to that
you mentioned well when you have a
feedback when you have a system looking
at itself but then that's
self-consciousness i'm just referring to
experience in and of itself yeah because
the experience is being
sensed by our body and you know our body
can
play tricks on us and can give us senses
that
do not really exist outside of the body
and they are just
self-created so you can you can imagine
phenomena like that
but it's all related to physical
processes that are happening
do you believe that there are wormholes
or stable wormholes
possibly aliens are using them no i at
the moment
you know there are people suggesting how
to construct wormholes how to
perhaps build time machines and but all
of these suggestions
again are highly speculative because we
don't have a quantum mechanical theory
of
gravity and without it um you know these
ideas may not
hold water you know so let's put it this
way we have no way of designing an
engineering project to build either a
time machine or a wormhole the current
knowledge is
very sketchy and the proposal that we
have
in various papers are all very
speculative
as for the fine-tuning of the universe
do you have any inklings as to why
it is the way that it is do you take lee
smullin's evolutionary black hole model
no um i you know i think that the
conditions we have in the universe were
dictated by
how it started uh you know around the
big bang
and so you know just like cosmic
inflation tries to explain various facts
and
uh once we have a quantum theory of
gravity we figure out where the universe
came from
you know what is the womb that the
umbilical cord of the universe was
connected to
and that would explain to us why it has
the properties that it has
so rather than guess it i would rather
go to that womb that created the
universe and
asked what are the reasons that we have
the conditions we have
so you believe that we can derive the
fundamental constants in some way
potentially yeah if we figure out what
happened
before the big bang using a quantum
theory of gravity perhaps
once again what we find in the universe
will be emerging out of those
conditions early conditions and the
theory and the you know the unifying
theory
which we don't have at the moment before
i get to audience questions
the last question i have well two i want
to know what you think is
the difference between wisdom and
intelligence and then i wanted to know
what you thought of wigner's
friends fingers friends thought
experiment or the thought experiment of
vigner's friend i'm sure you've heard of
it
about the collapse of the wave function
yeah so uh
first with respect to intelligence and
wisdom there is a very
uh big difference between them wisdom
is the ability to to identify the
essential
elements necessary to to answer
questions and and learn about
about the world so
it's a way of improving the efficiency
of us
figuring out the truth you know and
someone
that is wise gives you a shortcut
you can be very intelligent and just
examine all the exits from the highway
uh many of them would lead you into bad
neighborhoods
uh but if you are wise you will try to
figure out
which exit is the right one
and um so
so intelligence
may be an essential skill in pursuing
science
and you can become a world expert in a
particular niche
just like taking an exit from the
highway and that exit you can become
the world expert but it's not
necessarily the niche that matters the
most
and if you are wise you can figure out
which niche matters the most
if you're wise how do you determine
which one matters
which one is the right one i imagine
that depends on the goal but then i'm
wondering
well how do you decide on the goal you
have just what allows you to survive
you have to decide about the guiding
principles first so
for example to some people what matters
the most are
subjects of relevance to society
you know if it has an impact on society
because after all we live in a society
you know and whether we
address um how many extra dimensions
exist or
whether we address how to find a vaccine
to covet 19
or you know these are two different
questions with very different
impacts on society
so you might use that when you evaluate
what you want to do
if you want to help people then you work
on some
questions that matter to them now it
doesn't mean that they all have to be
medical
they could be questions that people care
about
right right so um in that way
since the public is funding science you
are paying respect
to the public if on the other hand you
ask yourself how many angels can sit on
the tip of a pin
and you get funded by the public and
then you say i don't care what the
public says and i don't care if i have
experiments to test my ideas
then that's a betrayal of the trust that
the society has in academia
and that is a good reason for the public
to say
that you know academia is part of the
elite
because because it's divorcing itself
from the interests of the public
so being wise is attending
to the interests of those who found fund
you
and that's an example okay what about if
there's no capitalism there's no funding
well
sorry in socialism you're also funded
there's no money we're hunt
hunter-gatherers can you be wise
yeah if you're a hunter and guard you
still have a purpose right you're trying
to hunt
so you're so for that purpose you
develop tools that are relevant
so instead of the relevance being to
society to the people that fund you
here the relevance is to your objectives
sorry what i'm trying to get at is how
do you know which goals
you're you're presuming a goal already
so what i'm wondering is
how do you determine which goal you
should follow oh okay i think well
the way i determine is personally that
doesn't mean that
everyone should operate this way but i i
um pay attention to the goals
that are most important you know that
are
that will make the biggest difference
you see uh
you can always work on on something in
the periphery that makes very little
difference to anyone
and nobody would bother you and you will
be happy you'll earn your living you go
to work you will smile
and people will smile at you and that's
it but the question is
does it matter to anyone or to yourself
do you feel will you feel at the age of
90 that you actually fulfilled your
uh life uh interests and the answer may
be no
you should have been more daring more
risk-taking
more willing to embark on things that
are difficult that will take a while to
figure out
but matter more so i look at myself
at that stage you know at a late age and
ask
what would i advise myself now to do
that would matter that will make a
difference and that's what i do
okay well let's get to some audience
questions steve scully here says is it
possible that the universe is infinite
that there is no
end to how large or small objects in the
universe
can be relative to one another and that
if the overall system
is to be comprehensible it is only by us
recognizing how
all of these apparently separate and
distinct different systems
actually share the same underlying
mechanics
yes read the question you understood the
question yeah i understood that
okay well most of the the answer to most
of the question is yes
it's quite possible that um in each
direction you know it's an infinite
series of sizes
and scales and uh but to me the most
interesting part of the question is
will the laws of physics apply
everywhere the same way
or will you have and then so far
the amazing thing is that in the region
that we can see that we can observe
it appears like the laws of physics
apply everywhere the same way
and that that's remarkable but it may
it's not guaranteed by any means
and of course people are searching for
deviations
because if you find a deviation you get
an overcross right
right that brings me to a question that
i have for you but it's more for an
experimentalist
do you always need a theory to interpret
the data or can you just interpret the
data without a theory so for example
collecting astronomical data we're
assuming that we're at no special
place in the universe and that the laws
are pretty much the same
throughout time
so can you interpret the data without a
theory can you even
make sense of the data without a theory
i don't think so i think
you always have to have something in the
back of your mind
because otherwise the data
is not telling you anything you have to
put it in
in a context so just to give you an
example
when i was a postdoc you know
astrophysical journals used to come in
print
it was not on the internet and so i went
to the library
at the institute for advanced study at
princeton and i saw that
before the 1980s there were photographs
published in print where you can see
giant arcs of light surrounding clusters
of galaxies and
people just ignored them the data was
there it was
it was printed uh you know in images
that were put on pape
in papers and nobody asked anything
about those arcs why are there arcs
you know like lightning strikes between
galaxies like sparks almost
well they look like arcs and then then
in the 1980s the subject of
gravitational lensing
uh became singular and then people
explained those arcs as
focusing of light by the force of
gravity you know so you have a cluster
of galaxies that acts on light
from a background source behind it let's
say a galaxy
sits far away behind the cluster and
then the light that comes from that
galaxy
is being gravitationally bent and
focused
at the observer and you end up with what
is called
an einstein ring einstein already
thought that this could happen
in 1940 so you can get a giant
arc of a background source that is
part of sort of a ring of
uh light that comes from gravitational
lensing and
once they realized that they said oh
that that's a good explanation for those
arcs
but the arcs existed in the literature
before
and people just didn't think about it in
that context so you can have data it's
just without
a sense of what the data may mean you
might actually
not not pay attention to it
362 asks do you still learn math and
physics in the same way you did
as you were when you were younger and if
not how has aging
and experience changed your learning
process right so
um i was always i'm not a good example
because
from a young age i was always most
interested in
ideas and then
the mathematical techniques that are
used to to
uh perfect them or
or demonstrate them uh and so um in that
sense
uh i'm actually more efficient now than
i was because
you know i i i i know the field
much better and so
if i were to meet a young version of
myself
i i could teach myself quite a bit uh
so i feel that i'm much stronger now
than i was at a younger age
uh because i i don't i don't waste as
much time in directions that would not
prove
use fruitful but
in terms of the techniques
it's true that after a certain age you
stop
learning new techniques most people
and so you continue to use what you've
learned then
during your studies in you know during
your phd and you continue to use that
uh but you use it on on subjects that
are new
um very few people do learn new
techniques and and
by that rejuvenate their skills people
do that
but since i was always about ideas uh
about thinking
on things that other people do not think
about
then the techniques were not
particularly
important for me and i remember when i
came as a postdoc i was asked
what kind of computer skills you have
and i said very minimal
during my phd i just used whatever i
needed in order to solve
uh the differential equations that i had
i didn't
master anything beyond that and the
person who hired me was
stunned he said how how come you didn't
learn
you know and um i should say that i had
a very
rather productive career even though i
didn't
learn much more computer skills since
then even so
it's possible yeah because
a lot of people have the technical
skills but they lack
the the imagination of the the ideas
so you play more in the realm of
concepts and ideas and how they relate
than you do with the mathematical
pedantry yeah so it's sort of like
you know sketching a blueprint of
a building rather than building it so
then who does the mathematical work you
just give it to a graduate student
a lot yeah students postdocs a lot of
people that i collaborate with
and with regard to learning new
techniques and constantly staying
updated
you said that some people do but
generally
let's say past the age of 30 or 40 i
don't know which
i'm asking you what time do you stop
doing it and it's it's not this
i know of people that are in their 50s
that are learning machine learning now
and
you know ai and uh so i
you know it really is a matter of
people that enjoy the the you know the
technical gymnastics and there are some
people that enjoy that and they're
they're not not many but i mean they're
a minority
do you think that instead of focusing on
artificial intelligence like you
mentioned we should focus on wisdom
so artificial wisdom so ah instead of ai
do you think that that's something we
should be focusing on or do you see like
how the heck would we even start that
project
oh i do think that it's interes a very
interesting idea i i haven't thought
about it before but
yeah you can think about designing a
system that will be wise
more efficient basically
rather than go and explore all
possibilities
brian keating asks our mutual friend
brian keating and by the way for those
listening brian keating
a link to his youtube channel be below
he said i'd love to know what his daily
routine is so that is you
and whether you've expected and even
regret the backlash
to your new fame so daily routine and
the backlash and how you feel about it
yeah well
um every since the pandemic started um
since
uh it's more than a year now uh every
morning at 5am
i go out and jog in the company of birds
ducks and rabbits and wild turkeys they
are they are very loud i
i see the same wild turkeys for a year
now along my path
what city are you in i'm a on a in a
suburb near boston
okay so it's cold oh yeah i go out
in any weather whether it's snows
whether it rains
whether it's freezing i you know i it's
just an aspect of nature that i enjoy i
enjoy going i i
enjoy very much being in the company of
nature rather than and i don't regard
people or my colleagues in particular as
part of nature because
nature is always gracious you know you
always learn something it's
i always enjoy nature i grew up on a
farm
so that my day starts at 5am and i
should say over
the the months of january february and
half of march
i would have back-to-back interviews
from 8 a.m until
7 00 p.m there were about 450 of them
all together
it was a huge huge uh
exhausting marathon that i had to be
engaged in just because of the interest
in my book
but that's very untypical because by now
it sort of
is fading away i mean the book is
already out for two months now
um and then uh by now i'm getting back
to my
regular routine which is writing papers
and and commentaries so
i should say the past 12 months were the
most productive
in my scientific career because i didn't
have to drive to work
i didn't have people getting into my
office
uninvited i didn't have the
administrative uh distractions that i
usually have
and so i could focus on creative work
and i wrote of the order of
46 scientific papers and
52
[Music]
commentaries mostly in scientific
american and then
a couple of books one of them is the one
that was published two months ago and
there is another one a textbook coming
out
at the end of june about life in the
cosmos
so it has been a very productive time
and you know frankly i can continue like
that
um you know for the next for the next
few years
uh without the problem that there is
always something interesting to work on
um and i enjoy the creative work for
i used to do leadership positions just
as a service to the community because at
some point i
realized that other people are not doing
their job properly when they are leading
a department or doing something else
sharing a committee
so i thought you know i should do it
just to make sure that things are done
according to the government the the
proper guiding principles what were they
doing
and what did you do that corrected it
many times they would they state
that you know the right ideas but
they would not really accomplish them in
practice and
that was a puzzle to me because i could
always see what needs to be done you
know in order
i giving a specific example no because
that was of
that will offend some people uh okay you
can be vegan
sorry give an example you can just
change it because i don't understand
what you mean by
what i mean you know like for example
when i became department chair
in 2011 i i continued three terms
that was the longest service in the
history of the department
i was the longest-serving department
chair um and then
one thing from the beginning was that i
was always straightforward with people i
would tell them
the situation as is right i never
manipulate people i never hide things
from them
and you might think that that's a
negative politically because
very often in politics you have to
maneuver in a way that would
people would not know exactly what is
going on
but i found it to be a i didn't
care so much because i said you know if
if i give up on my
service i would go back to to research
and i'll be happy at that i'm doing the
service
uh you know just in order to serve the
community and
uh so i was straightforward and it
turned out to be a great
asset because people never suspected me
doing things behind their back and
they always trusted my dealings with
things and
and then i i put an important item to
promote
minorities and women in the department
and you know i hired
in that direction and there was not much
resistance
uh from my colleagues to that and uh so
i
you know i felt that i did accomplish
something in nine years
uh so you know transparency
uh people from underprivileged
circumstances to
have the proper training so that they
can become leaders
you know these are the kinds of
principles that i felt strongly about
and
i tried to promote and that previously i
didn't feel were promoted enough
uh but now you know that i finished my
third term and
just um you know in july 2020
then i can go back to doing creative
work and
that's what i enjoy the most you wrote
this book while you were the chair
the book was yes um that's right
you were a productive man well i
i i i i'm a no-nonsense kind of
person in the sense that you know when i
have a task i i work on it and
i work most of the day how do you
balance that with
spending time with your wife and i'm not
sure if you have kids but whatever your
personal life
i have two daughters uh yeah i mean
uh i do spend time with them but but one
of them is 15 the other one is 19 and
um they are sort of independent by now
the the two
i'm surrounded by uh three wonderful
women that were the muses for my
book uh and they support me
in a lot of different ways provide the
right balance for my life so
i'm sort of at this point in my life i'm
self-sustained and can do creative work
you know that's the the
the best you can hope for that you don't
depend on
other people that have agendas that are
not necessarily aligned with your
principles
um so that that's a good place to be in
and i'm very happy to be in that place
when you were doing podcasts for 11
hours a day back
a couple months ago including now even
why do you say that you had to do it
your publisher pushed you to do it or
you wanted no no
i felt that it's a platform that allows
me to communicate what i believe in
to the public had nothing to do some
people argue that
maybe i'm doing it to sell my book i
told my
my publicist that it's not for that
purpose that i'm
doing it to convey a message the
publicist was saying good job avi and i
said
i'm not trying to sell my book even so
when the book became a bestseller that
was not my objective at all i
i wouldn't care less if you know if it
sold just a few hundred copies and
that's it and
what i would like to communicate is a
message to the public and i communicate
through my book and through these
appearances and
and it got them huge attention from from
the public i should say you know like
there was a advice
video that received the one and a half
million views within
a week and a half and you know
there was of course the interviews with
joe rogan and and
uh and some other people got a huge um
amount of attention so so in that sense
i i did bring my message to the public
um
and that's what i wanted and then now i
can move on and
and you know write additional books do
the views make you feel happy do you
feel giddy do you share the news with
your wife like look this got a million
views or do you read the comments
how do you view your own appearances um
i i let the publicist look into that um
and and there were of course other
opportunities that were opened up
um that involved uh documentaries or
or films and there were of other
25 filmmakers and producers that
approached us as a result
but we should see if anything comes out
congratulations that's not easy as a
filmmaker i know that that's not
a that's not something to be sneezed at
so 20 years ago 2001 you were married
and your wife said don't go on social
media how the heck does she know about
social media in 2001
yeah because well back then um there
were some versions of it
and then uh myspace i'm assuming
yeah yeah myspace i i forgot but
you know i usually i do not deviate if i
agree to something and i maintained the
course and
when facebook appeared and twitter and
so forth i
kept my promise to her and
how attractive you were and how much
girls will be messaging you wasn't about
keeping you that car that's an
interesting insight i i wouldn't um
yeah perhaps she was thinking about that
yeah i i don't know exactly why but then
i'm grateful for working out it worked
out in the sense that
it kept me honest and uh independent of
others
okay barfi man again his also his name
is also ryan collins he said
can you ask him about virtual black
holes and spin network evolution
how might a superposition of spin
network evolutions brackets spin foams
fluctuate
um
well we so again the structure of space
and time you know is a matter of
the the unified theory of quantum
gravity which we don't have at the
moment so
john wheeler was a physicist who thought
about the space-time foam
as the way that space and time appear
on very tiny scales that's not the way
that string theory thinks
of it right now and um there are all
these extra dimensions and
uh so i would say the verdict is still
out as to what's going on
with space and time and let's just
keep an open mind jeff b says
number one have they confirmed yet if
blc1 narrow band radio signal
detected in december 2020 by the parks
radio telescope
hopefully you know about this came from
proxima centauri
or was it just earth-based local
interference
that's an excellent question and most
likely it's earth-based
the reason i say that is because the
frequency was very steady
didn't really drift much and it was a
very narrow band of frequencies that was
detected and
if it came if it were to come from a
habitable
uh planet around proxima centauri then
you would see some drift in the
frequency because of the motion of that
planet
well beyond the the limits uh
but of course it could have come from a
planet not in the habitable zone
um based on the
the fact that it was one telescope in
australia i think we should be very
suspicious because the same telescope
reported the fast radio burst repeating
fast radio burst
a few years ago that ended up being the
uh that they found that it comes only
during lunch time and
uh then realized that it's the door of a
microwave oven that was opened
prematurely right right
so i would say there is a like high
likelihood that
it's it's local um and the only way to
find out is to have
another observatory at a different
location finding the same source so
we really need the confirmation before
we assume that it is
uh associated with proxima centauri
rabbit skywalker says i really would
like to hear his opinion about the
claims
from former israeli director of the
space program
ham ashad brought forward you must have
heard about it he must have heard about
it referring to
you and i wonder what avi thinks about
this story
yeah so my reply to that is he didn't
really provide any evidence and that
goes back to what we discussed before
that uh
if you don't have a document supporting
uh your claim or or some other type of
evidence then
to me it sounds like no journalist
should cover that story because
otherwise you create a lot of noise in
the system without much signal
about there being evidence there's
someone named kevin knuth i don't
or kevin knuth i don't know if you've
heard of him he's a physicist from
albany
you've heard of him yes definitely okay
well i'm speaking to him in a few hours
just for the people listening to i'm
speaking to him in a few hours
he says that he's analyzed some of the
data of the
ufos or uaps i believe they're called
now and he has showed that
through analysis the amount of
acceleration is
incomparable to anything that we can
produce and it's
well i guess you can take that as
evidence
what do you think about that have you
seen that paper of his so
anything to do with unidentifying flying
objects
or aerial phenomena my take on those
is simple that we should deploy
state-of-the-art instruments cameras or
audio sensors in the same locations and
try to collect data just like a
scientific experiment
rather than rely on instruments that
were not optimized for that purpose that
you know pilots have access to and
or rely on reports that came from many
years ago that
we cannot really check um and so i think
that
all the ufo and uap supporters
should fund a scientific mission
experiment to monitor the earth
yeah monitor those locations if you
think that they are and basically if we
see anything unusual
it will be documented in a
scientifically credible way
rather than rely on those unoptimized
reports that you know the images are
always fuzzy it could be something in
the instrument it could be
something else in the sky that is an
optical illusion
could be many things so um i would
highly recommend doing a scientific
credible scientific
experiment and you know it shouldn't be
too expensive and it would save us
a lot of time instead of discussing it
let's just
let we should let the evidence
dictate yes of course of course i know
you got to go how did but how can we do
that because i imagine that the ufos are
so small and they're so sporadic
that to monitor the entire earth is not
cheap so how can
conceivably that be done you don't need
the entire earth you can just do it
in the spots where detections were
reported and
nowadays we have technologies that
didn't exist decades ago and
uh we should you know it's it should not
be too expensive that
i'm sure that at the level of tens of
millions of dollars
one can do a state-of-the-art experiment
to check if there is anything unusual
if we don't see anything unusual then uh
it must mean that these were artifacts
of the
instruments or some illusions amjad
hussain had a couple questions that i
wasn't able to get to during the
interview but i emailed avi
directly and here's the exchange
professor avi are there aliens on earth
living sharing the planet with us in a
non-electromagnetic realm dimension
consciousness like dark matter energy
where we don't know their existence
and then he had another question number
two do fundamental particles in nature
have proto-consciousness
meaning that an electron feels its own
intrinsic state
of charge spin etc does consciousness
equal existence
avi replied saying the answers to both
questions are no
as far as we know scientifically
avi you gotta go thank you so much i
appreciate your time it was a pleasure
talking to you
it was a pleasure to to answer all these
questions and there were
excellent questions all of them i
enjoyed it very much
you